There probably hasn't been a bigger or more
dynamic year in recent television history
than 2018.
Among all this great TV, certain moments proved
unforgettable in ways that, for better or
for worse, fans will be discussing for years.
Here are the biggest TV moments of 2018, the
good and the bad.
Henry Winkler has been a TV legend for more
than 40 years.
In the 1970s, he was probably the most popular
cultural figure in America for his work on
Happy Days portraying leather-wearing, jukebox-smacking
ladies' man Arthur Fonzarelli, a.k.a. Fonzie.
He received his first of six Emmy nominations
way back in 1976 for that role, but it took
until 2018 for Winkler, widely regarded as
one of the nicest guys in Hollywood, to finally
take home that prized statue for television
excellence.
For his role as acting coach Gene Cosineau
on HBO's dark comedy Barry, Winkler won the
first trophy of the night at the 2018 Emmy
Awards and the audience leapt to their feet
as the former Fonzie delivered the speech
he'd written in 1976.
The best part?
Telling his kids, who are full-grown adults,
that it was past their bedtimes.
If you’ve been anywhere even close to the
Internet in the past few months, then you
know that prolific comic book writer and editor
Stan Lee, whose cameos in nearly every Marvel
Movie made him a familiar figure to billions
of people across the world, passed away in
November.
“I guess one person can make a difference.
nuff said.”
With the news that the co-creator of the Marvel
Universe had died, accolades, praise, and
tributes came pouring in from people in all
walks of life.
And then Real Time host Bill Maher weighed
in with a piece on his show’s blog called
"Adulting," a disrespectful dismissal of comics
in general, and by extension, Lee in particular.
Claiming that Lee had only ever inspired his
fans to “go watch a movie, I guess,” Maher,
who has never shied away from using snide
comments to get attention, advised comic book
fans to grow up and move on to “big boy
books without the pictures.”
Presumably he means his books, which are all
about how smart Bill Maher is for knowing
about sarcasm.
Maher dealt with the fallout of his remarks
on Hulu's Larry King Now.
He didn't apologize, claiming that he wasn't
even aware he'd caused a hubbub, and clarified
that he'd meant that thinking comic books
and superhero movies could have artistic worth
was just the symptom of a stupid culture.
Not a good look, especially given the circumstances.
Donald Glover's first time hosting Saturday
Night Live in May 2018 was timed to promote
his role as young Lando in Solo: A Star Wars
Story.
Unfortunately, between Atlanta, This Is America,
and absolutely killing it on NBC's late-night
institution, that movie might be the least
memorable thing Glover did all year.
Glover shined in every single sketch he was
a part of.
He played a sleazy lawyer defending Jurassic
World over the many violent dinosaur-related
deaths for which it was certainly liable.
He did musical comedy in a high-concept sketch
as Razz P. Berry, a scorned man who steps
out of an '80s music video to exact revenge
on who he very wrongly thinks is a cheating
girlfriend.
Glover also served as the musical guest under
his stage name, Childish Gambino, launching
the single that turned out to be one of the
most controversial songs of the year.
More than 100 million people tune in to watch
the Super Bowl every year, making the halftime
show one of the most criticized and scrutinized
performances of the year, if only because
of the sheer magnitude of the gig.
With that many eyes, musicians need to bring
their A-Game, and when Justin Timberlake headlined
the spectacular for the first time since the
infamous 2004 performance with Janet Jackson,
he certainly did that… assuming the A stands
for awful.
While dressed in a camouflage outfit and a
red bandana that made him look like a golden
retriever, Timberlake pushed his way through
a medley of hits like "Rock Your Body" and
"SexyBack."
He had reportedly planned to employ a Prince
hologram in his set, but canceled it after
objections from, among others, Prince himself,
who once remarked that a technological re-creation
of a dead musician would be "the most demonic
thing imaginable."
Instead, he delivered a lackluster cover of
"I Would Die 4 U" alongside an image of Minnesota's
finest projected onto a sheet.
It only served as a reminder of the controversy,
not to mention inviting a comparison to Prince’s
own far superior halftime show in the 2007
Super Bowl.
Death is a major part of The Walking Dead,
and every season brings at least one hard-hitting
tragedy as fan-favorite characters struggle
against endless hordes of zombies.
In 2018, the show gave us one of its most
excruciating, yet heartbreakingly beautiful
deaths when it killed off Carl Grimes, a character
who'd been with the show from the beginning,
and who represented hope for the future.
Carl had already endured plenty of tragedies,
including the death of his mother while giving
birth and the violent loss of his right eye,
but remained strong, confident, and brave.
In the end, though, Carl was bitten, and chose
to end his life in a way that revealed his
inner decency.
The good, and heartbreaking news is that he
had time to put his affairs in order — bonding
with his little sister Judith and writing
poignant letters to his loved ones, making
his death even more effective.
While it still has plenty of fans, The Walking
Dead gradually shed millions of viewers who
were tired of being manipulated by narrative
stunts.
Season-ending cliffhangers, fake-out character
deaths, and killing off fan-favorite characters
in a parade of misery simply wore viewers
out.
In late 2018, The Walking Dead once again
messed with fans.
Earlier in the year, star Andrew Lincoln announced
that he was leaving the show.
AMC heavily promoted the last episodes featuring
Lincoln as Rick Grimes, and most viewers assumed
he'd die.
It certainly looked that way, when he blew
up a bridge to kill some zombies, and got
impaled on metal, only to be airlifted to
safety.
Right after this episode aired, AMC announced
that Lincoln would go on to star in three
new movies about Rick, meaning that all that
fuss wasn’t for a send-off, it was just
promotion for a spin-off instead.
It's strange and uncomfortable to consider
a world without Adventure Time.
Pendleton Ward's wildly imaginative, funny,
tragic, and strange Cartoon Network series
changed the game for TV animation upon its
debut back in 2010.
Over nearly 300 episodes, it created an elaborate
land called Ooo, that was slowly revealed
to be a post-apocalyptic world that had been
nearly destroyed by the Great Mushroom War,
so named for the mushroom clouds left by nuclear
weapons.
In the one-hour final episode, the Great Gum
War ends not with the horrific violence of
the Great Mushroom War (which led to the Land
of Ooo's formation), but with peace, as the
leaders of the two factions agree to rule
in tandem.
But then GOLB, the most evil thing in existence,
sees that calm as an opening to return, and
does all kinds of awful things.
In the end, goodness wins out, and viewers
see BMO becoming the future ruler of Ooo.
BMO tells the story of the war to two young
adventurers named Shermy and Beth, who bear
a striking resemblance to Finn and Jake.
It was a thrilling, if bittersweet, finish
to a show that already ranks among modern
animated classics.
Reboots were huge in 2018, including the reboot
of the 2000s pop culture sensation Queer Eye
for the Straight Guy.
Both then and now, the show sends five gay-identifying
lifestyle experts to help slovenly hetero
dudes clean up their acts and better their
lives.
The 2018 version turned down the camp and
turned up the emotion, as a brand new "Fab
Five" based in Atlanta helped individuals
improve more than just their wardrobes, making
connections across race, religion, and economic
status, demonstrating that healing was possible
in a divided culture.
But one moment rang totally flat, reminding
viewers that this particular reality show
is very real.
On the third episode of the Queer Eye reboot,
the gang piles into a car to go help out a
Georgia man named Cory.
Before they get there, a cop pulls them over.
Cast member Karamo Brown, an African-American
man, is behind the wheel, and viewers can
see his face fall flat as he faces a situation
with the potential to get tense at best.
The officer sternly approaches the vehicle
and asks Brown to get out, which Brown's co-stars
firmly protest.
But hey, don't worry, it's all a joke!
This cop is just Henry, the guy who nominated
his friend, and someone who really doesn't
understand that making marginalized people
feel threatened isn't all that funny.
The only good part of it was that Karamo was
able to discuss his fear in a way that was
accessible to both the audience and to Cory,
a conversation that brought a whole lot of
depth to a show that’s usually focused on
how to tuck in your shirt.